now to find the kasim outpost
so
not enough
these fury won't go down easily
this is no illusion the road is blocked
i must go through the kasim outpost to
the west
[Music]
help me
still recharges
impossible
i can't
they should have run when they had the
chance
she's discovered
camp lying in wait for a hero
of incredible prowess
no way i need fury i have heard tales of
this hero
wading to our ranks and slaughtering us
as if we were children
i will not sleep again tonight i fear
belial lord of lies is the most
elusive of the seven evils and is a
master of deceit
it is said that he manipulated azmodan
into revolt against the prime evils
this began the burning captain of the
god
you are hereby ordered to send a band of
your most loyal men to
secure the kasim open the gate you must
be mad
but if you're intent on the rushing
headlong
here you are delivered unto me as a
sacrifice
a gift from lord belial it is you
who are the sacrifice he said no he
would never betray me
strike her down
but here is the truth not a moment too
soon they plan to sacrifice us to belial
iron wolves take back the town
these seventeen demons are elijah's
favored servants
and he has granted them some of his
skill and europe
and illusion now three deceivers
themselves in the familiar form of their
enemies companions
and friends waiting to strike when the
moment is opportune
has magda reached al qaeda yes then the
sooner you open this